ChChantal Hébert, Paul Wells
etet Hélène Buzzetti, bonsoir.
- - Bonsoir!
- - On va écouter Monsieur Ducls
ququi a été très clair cet aprè-
mimidi. Chantal, vous en parliez
hihier au panel. Non seulement e
n'n'est pas une bonne idée, mais
jeje vais vous expliquer pourqu,
vovous ne pourrez peut-être pas
rerevenir.
- - Ce qu'on dit c'est d'ici
lele 23 décembre, il faut être
prprudent. Maintenant, est-ce
ququ'on laissera, ne serait-ce e
popour la santé mentale, quelqus
JEJEAN-YVES DUCLOS,
miministre fédéral de la Santé
- - Toutes les provinces doivent
acaccélérer leur processus
dede vaccination de troisièmes
dodoses avec les informations
quque l'on a maintenant, qu'on
n'n'avait pas il y a à peine
ququelques semaines.
OnOn s'aperçoit qu'une troisième
dodose est absolument essentiele
popour protéger contre l'infectn
etet contre le risque de maladie
sésévère, et donc le risque
d'd'hospitalisation. Alors,
c'c'est ce qu'on va devoir fair.
C'C'est la priorité première
popour toutes les provinces,
y y compris pour le Québec,
d'd'augmenter considérablement
lele rythme de vaccination.
NoNous avons présentement un
ryrythme de vaccination au pays
ququi est à peu près le quart
dede ce qu'il était durant l'ét.
DoDonc, durant l'été, juin,
jujuillet, août, on vaccinait
ququatre fois plus de gens par
jojour. Je pense qu'on a besoin
d'd'arriver assez rapidement
àà ce rythme à nouveau.
- - Cet extrait, ce n'était pas
susur le voyage, on parle de la
trtroisième dose. Il y avait dex
memessages à Ottawa. Ne voyagez
papas, et la troisième dose, il
fafaut accélérer le rythme.
ChChantal Hébert, il a dit
d'd'ailleurs, ça s'assombrit. Il
fafaut redoubler de prudence ete
rarapidité.
- - Oui, et ça tombe bien que vs
avaviez passé cet extrait plutôt
quque celui sur les voyages pare
quque la priorité franchement,
leles voyages, c'est une d'chose
ququi s'est faite dire, le premr
miministre hier soir quand il a
paparlé aux provinces, c'est
cocorrect, personne ne va
s's'opposer à ce qu'on dise aux
gegens de moins voyageait, mais
leles provinces ont dit
quque si vous voulez qu'on est s
mamains pour mettre des seringus
dadans les bras, ne comptez pas
susur nous pour aller faire des
tetests dans les aéroports.
- - Paul, donc insistance lourde
susur l'accélération de la
trtroisième dose. On vient
d'd'entendre le ministre qui dit
ququ'on aimerait avoir le rythme
dede cet été.
- - Oui, et on verra bien si c't
popossible.
J'J'essaie depuis quelques jours
d'd'un masque pour avoir ma
trtroisième dose à moi.
MaMalheureusement, je ne serai
éléligible que le 24 décembre.Ça
totombe mal.
- - Un cadeau de Noël :
- - En Ontario, c'est carrément
imimpossible. On verra si ça
s's'améliore dans les prochains
jojours.
OnOn est toujours assez loin de
l'l'incertitude sur la questione
cece à quoi en fait face. Est-ce
quque c'est quelque chose de
vrvraiment néfaste et dangereux?
EsEst-ce que c'est quelque chose
dede si anodin que ce serait
ququasiment mieux de l'attraper
quque de l'éviter? On ne sait ps
enencore. Mais par excès de
prprudence, je pense que la
réréponse des provinces et du
féfédéral et ce qu'il faut si tt
esest qu'on puisse fairere ce qn
esessaie de faire. Et là, je sus
loloin d'être certain de cette
ququestion de logistique.
- - Il y a deux questions de
mamathématiques. Ça peut être
ananodin pour 90 % des gens
mamais si il y a 3 % qui se
rerendent à l'hôpital, la capacé
hohospitalière, c'est l'obsessin
dedepuis le début de cette cris,
quque ça pompe des ressources et
onon le voit quand même, ça mone
plplus rapidement les
hohospitalisations.
EnEn Ontario, ça a baissé un peu
auaujourd'hui mais au Québec, ça
momonte.
- - Il faut quand même apporter
quque clairement, cette troisièe
dodose, elle soit réellement
efefficace pour éviter les
hohospitalisations et les décès
chchez les personnes plus âgées
. . Je pense en Israël où on a
fafait de cohortes, des 50 ans t
plplus, les gens qui avaient reu
dede dose versus les gens qui
avavaient reçu trois doses et pr
ceces gens, le taux de décès avt
didiminué de 90 % avec la
trtroisième dose. Clairement, pr
leles personnes plus âgées, c'et
trtrès efficace. C'est moins clr
popour les personnes plus jeune.
EsEst-ce que vraiment la priorié
dodoit être absolument de donner
unune trtroisième dose plus vite
popour les personnes de 18 ou 20
anans? La science ne semble pas
êêtre claire encore là-dessus.
J'J'ai trouvé un peu bête le
cacalcul un peu mathématiques de
MoMonsieur Duclos de dire que ln
fafaisait quatre fois plus de
vavaccins cet été. Cet été,
onon vaccinait tout le monde. E-
cece que c'est vraiment la
prpriorité en ce moment de
vavacciner même les plus jeunes?
LaLa question se pose.
- - Beaucoup de gens le disent,
avavec des blouses blanches, ils
lele disent. Ils disent qu'on et
mimieux protégé. En Ontario, ses
1818 ans et plus. Mais dans les
fafaits, il manque demande comme
auau Québec.
- - La bonne nouvelle pour Paul,
c'c'est qu'il est éligible
mamaintenant parce que aujourd'i
enen Ontario, on a dit trois mos
plplutôt que c'est ce. La
nonouvelle, la mauvaise nouvelle
popour Paul, c'est qu'on a dit e
totout le monde peut s'inscrire.
OnOn voit le même pattern qu'ona
vuvu avec le gouvernement fédér.
SiSi on ferme les frontières,
c'c'est une chose de le dire et
c'c'est une autre chose de
l'l'exécuter. C'est déjà diffice
enen Ontario pour quelqu'un quia
5050 ans et plus de trouver un
rerendez-vous après six mois.
AlAlors vendredi, quand tout le
momonde, 18 ans et plus pourront
s's'inscrire, bonne chance. C'et
lele temps des fêtes.
LeLes gens qui donnent ces
vavaccins, comme les autres, mon
fafaire une pause.
C'C'est un peu léger de dire...t
enen plus, on a mis beaucoup
d'd'énergie dans toutes les
prprovinces à vacciner les
enenfants. C'est un peu léger de
didire : il faudrait revenir au
ryrythme du mois de juillet.
- - C'est facile à dire, mais le
gogouvernement n'a pas prouvé
ququ'il était capable de faire
ququelque chose d'efficace avec
leles tests aux frontières.
- - Chantal soulève un très bon
popoint. Le fait d'ouvrir à tous
fafaire en sorte que les persons
popour qui cette troisième dose
seserait la plus efficace, c'es-
àà-dire des personnes plus âgée,
nene seront peut-être pas les
prpremières à se faire vacciner.
CÇa illustre le danger de voulor
alaller trop vite en ouvrant les
poportes à tout le monde tout de
susuite.
- - Très bien. Il y a beaucoup e
gegens qui ont posé des questios
àà Monsieur Duclos en disant : e
trtrouvez-vous pas que le Québec
dedevrait revenir avec le...
ququ'il faut sortir de cette
lologique exactement combien de
pepersonnes, il faut entrer dans
unune logique de
reresponsabilisation et de ne ps
avavoir une multitude de contacs
didifférents en quelques joursÇa
pepeut presque être pire. Je
reregardais ce matin, je me suis
amamusé, les journaux partout,
c'c'est rare les gens qui parlet
quque de 20 ou 15 personnes. Les
sasanté publique en Occident die
: : le moins possible.
- - Mais ça veut dire aussi quee
miministre de la santé, celui du
QuQuébec ou d'ailleurs et le
prpremier ministre ne se promène
papas en disant : est correcte,
unune fête à 20 personnes.
CÇa n'envoie pas le bon message.
OnOn le voit et on l'entend,
esest correcte à 20 personnes. l
n'n'y a pas vraiment de balise -
dededans. Aujourd'hui, le
gogouvernement de l'Alberta a
anannoncé non seulement qu'il
lilibéralisait ces mesures mais
ququ'en plus, les noms vaccinait
popouvaient se réunir avec les
vavacciner pour Noël. Si vous
pepensez que les gens sont mêlé,
imimaginez recevoir ces message.
- - En Ontario, il n'y a pas ce
dédébat de combien de gens à
l'l'intérieur des maisons?
- - On n'a pas de chiffres. On a
seseulement une consigne, il fat
fafaire attention. Si on dit d'e
papart comme on dit au Québec, n
didit la responsabilisation et e
l'l'autre part, on dit 20
pepersonnes. Ma personne, c'est
bebeaucoup plus facile à reteni.
- - Sacré de la confusion.
BoBon, c'est reparti de plus
bebelle, on n'en a parlé il y a
ququelques jours, le débat sur a
loloi 21. Votre collègue
chchroniqueure, Chantal, ce mat,
ilil y a eu un éditorial, mais e
fofond est le même. Je vous fais
écécouter. D'ailleurs, je vous
momontre avant Bob Rae. Vous alz
mimieux comprendre l'échange à a
chchambre des communes.
L'L'ambassadeur du Canada à la
chchambre d'commune qui a écrit
quque cette loi est profondément
didiscriminatoire et elle va à
l'l'encontre de la déclaration
ununiverselle des droits de
l'l'homme. Ça a donné cet échane
àà la chchambre des communes.
YVYVES-FRANÇOIS BLANCHET,
chchef, Bloc québécois
- - Est-ce que le premier minise
pepeut, parce que c'est de toute
évévidence ce e qu'il convient e
fafaire, rappeler l'ambassadeur
Ray immédiatement?
- - Je suis en profond désaccord
avavec la loi 21. Je ne trouve s
quque dans une société libre,
ququelqu'un devrait perdre sa jb
àà cause de sa religion.
NoNous allons continuer d'être
dudu côté des Québécois qui
eueux-mêmes sont choqués et déçs
quque Fatemah Anvari ait perdu
soson emploi à cause de
sasa religion. Et nous appuyons
etet nous suivons les Québécois
ququi, eux, défendent leurs dros
enen cour devant cette loi
ququ'ils trouvent injuste.
- - Le premier ministre cautione
unune diffamation contre une loi
etet une nation tout aussi
lélégitime que ses prétentions
àà lui!
- - Nous défendons, au Québec,
lala liberté de religion.
C'C'est pour ça qu'il y a
tetellement de Québécois
ququi sont surpris et déçus
dede voir la jeune Fatemah Anva,
enenseignante, perdre son emploi
paparce qu'elle est musulmane.
- - On a comme libéré la parole.
LaLa campagne est passée. Hélèn,
MoMonsieur Trudeau, en tout cas,
onon a l'impression qu'il se set
plplus à l'aise d'aller au fonde
sasa pensée.
- - Je ne sais pas par rapport à
cecela. C'est certain qu'il pare
dede manière plus volubile parce
ququ'en campagne électorale, ce
n'n'était pas très vendeur d'alr
frfrapper sur la loi 21 au Québc
llà où on voulait faire des
gagains. Mais la position de
MoMonsieur Trudeau n'a jamais
chchangé. Il a toujours été
cocontre. J'ai un peu tiqué
auaujourd'hui quand il a même dt
ququelque chose comme :
esest-ce qu'on demande au juge t
auaux policiers de quelle relign
ilils sont? Je ne suis pas certn
dede comprendre comment
ininterpréter cette déclaration.
EsEst-ce que ça veut dire qu'ile
sasait pas qu'au Québec la loi 1
ininterdit aussi aux policiers t
auau juge de porter un symbole
rereligieux? Je ne trouve pas
ququ'il a changé radicalement de
poposition. Ça me fait un peu
ririgoler du côté du Bloc
ququébécois parce que c'est
ququelque chose qui revient
sosouvent. On n'en avait parlé n
202019. On s'était dit qu'il
alallait attendre après l'électn
popour contester la loi. On noua
reremit le même disque à
l'l'élection de 2021. Maintenan,
onon nous dit qu'on va attendre
élélections québécoises et après
cecelle de 2022 pour contester.
JeJe crois que fondamentalement,
c'c'est qu'Ottawa ne voit pas
nénécessairement qu'est-ce qui
popourrait apporter de plus dans
unune contestation judiciaire qe
nene le font déjà les gens qui
cocontestent cette loi.
- - Paul, il y a eu beaucoup
d'd'articles de pluie. Ces sorts
pupubliquement jeudi soir derni,
l'l'exemple de cette enseignante
ququi a dû être taxée compte teu
dede son voile. On sent vraiment
ququ'il y a beaucoup de gens qui
didisent que c'est le moment de
s's'exprimer contre cette loi qe
l'l'on juge injuste.
- - Oui, et on voit par ailleurs
dedes textes venant des Québécos
ququi nous disent de nous taire
paparce que stratégiquement, ce
n'n'est pas bien d'inciter les
QuQuébécois comme cela. J'ai vun
ararticle de l'ancien sénateur t
édéditeur de la presse il y a
ququelques heures qui disaient n
pepeu cela. Mais, les gens, qu's
sosoient au Québec ou hors Québ,
nene sont pas tentés par les
cacalculs statisticiens. Ils vot
s's'exprimer comme plein d'autrs
ququestions sans vraiment penser
auaux statistiques ça peut avoi.
- - Maintenant.
- - Si Justin Trudeau a changé e
didiscours depuis quelques jour,
c'c'est vrai qu'il jouait sur ls
dedeux registres depuis quelques
anans. Il n'était pas forcément
d'd'accord avec la loi mais pour
l'l'instant, il ne faisait rien.
EÉventuellement, il pourrait
fafaire quelque chose.
IlIls enragent contre l'injustie
enen pleine chambre des commune.
IlIl sent la pression de ses
dédéputés, des députés de
l'l'opposition qui ont une opinn
susur cette question. Les gens
n'n'ont pas vraiment le goût dee
tataire depuis quelques jours.
- - Il y a eu un changement non
seseulement de temps, mais
MoMonsieur Singh a changé
d'd'attitude en disant qu'il fat
ququ'on participe à la
cocontestation. Là encore, un
chchangement. Comment vous voyez
cece débat se réinstaller?
- - Je suis d'accord avec Paul.
J'J'ai eu l'impression en écoutt
JuJustin Trudeau aujourd'hui qul
paparlait d'abord à son caucus
ouou à une grande partie de son
cacaucus et ce n'est pas parce
ququ'on le dit plus fort
ququ'on dit quelque chose de
didifférent. Dans ce cas-ci, ila
didit la même chose, la même che
quque toujours, sauf qu'il a die
plplus fort. Dans le cas de Bob
RaRae, je comprends totalement
cece qu'il essaie de dire mais
nénéanmoins, il était à
l'l'extérieur de son devoir.
CeCe n'est pas le rôle d'un
amambassadeur qui représente le
CaCanada aux Nations unies de
faire la leçon à une province ou
unun autre. C'est un autre rôle.
S'S'il veut le ravoir, il peut t
ilil a droit à ses opinions. Mas
llà-dessus, il était à côté de
sasacoche. D'autre part et
fifinalement, je n'impression qe
çaça fait l'affaire de François
LeLegault à la veille d'une
cacampagne électorale qu'il y at
unune levée de boucliers à ce
susujet de cette façon-là, qui
vivient de l'extérieur du Québe.
CoComme vous avez parlé de mon
cocollègue, sans dire ce qu'il
avavait recommandé, Andrew Poje
didit que le gouvernement du
CaCanada devrait retirer des
trtransferts pour la santé au
QuQuébec jusqu'à ce que la loi 1
didisparaisse. Je peux vous faie
unune prédiction, il n'y a aucun
chchef à Ottawa qui va embarquer
llà-dedans.
- - Où se déplacera le débat?
DeDevant les tribunaux, on le
sasait, mais comment le débat va
sese dessiner au Canada dans les
prprochains mois? C'est un surst
paparce qu'il y a eu un exemplùu
vovous croyez que ça va se
reretirer?
- - Est déjà un peu plus calme
quque vendredi. On a appris que
l'l'enseignante n'a pas perdu sn
ememploi. Elle va animer un
atatelier d'alphabétisation et
d'd'écriture sur des thèmes de a
didiversité. Elle devient en
ququelque sorte le symbole
dede la résistance entre la loi1
auau sein même du Québec. Elle a
l'l'air de trouver cela,
unune tâche assez intéressante.
MaMais la loi 21, ça va aller àa
cocour suprême du Canada à coup
ssûr. Je sais pertinemment que
leles juges de la cour suprême
l'l'attendent.
EtEt les chefs des partis
popolitiques aussi. Et tout le
momonde ajuste son discours en
fofonction de cela.
- - Hélène, tout le monde ajuste
soson discours. Et la chef libél
auau Québec aussi. Mais elle a t
ququ'elle était contre la loi.
MaMais la loi, c'est la loi.
- - Celui qui a changé le plus
d'd'opinion, c'est vraiment M.
SiSingh. Durant la campagne, il
n'n'a pas dit qu'il voulait
paparticiper à une contestation.
MaMaintenant qu'il n'a plus de
popotentiel de succès au Québec,
ilil dit qu'il va y participer.e
plplus coincé, c'est Monsieur
O'O'Toole parce qu'il y a des
coconservateurs qui sont d'accod
avavec la